die bundesregierung warnt vor einem
gas-notstand ab dem herbst gas droht ein
immer knapper werden es gut zu werden
die industrie hat große ängste ab der
kalten jahreszeit noch genügend gas zur
verfügung steht viele bürger sähen jetzt
in diesen wochen dass die rechnung für
gas immer weiter steigen und das dicke
ende steht uns im land wahrscheinlich in
den nächsten monaten noch bevor und
gleichzeitig möchte die bundesregierung
gas weiter für die verstromung einsetzen
und das finde ich fast nichts zusammen
und deswegen finde ich dass wir alle
kapazitäten heben sollten um
stromkapazitäten auch in zukunft
sicherzustellen in deutschland und damit
wir gas nicht für die
stromversorgung brauchen daher mein
appell an robert habeck sorgen sie dafür
dass die laufzeiten der kernkraftwerke
verlängert werden wenn wir brauchen die
kernkraftwerke damit strom und damit
energie in deutschland auch in zukunft
bezahlbar bleiben
würden sie zustimmen da stimme ich auf
jeden fall zu weil ich bringt das ja
gerade frisch mit ich habe heute noch im
laufe des tages mit verschiedenen
kleineren größeren unternehmern
gesprochen die alle ziemlich resigniert
und frustriert sind dass sie sagen wird
unser geschäft überhaupt noch übers jahr
gehen das heißt also viele werden das
problem haben dass sie wahrscheinlich
sagen ob das jetzt im herbst noch fließt
oder nicht das ist dann für meine
wohnung entscheidend aber fakt ist auf
jeden fall eines sie sind in großer
sorge sie sind wütend und natürlich und
das gebe ich auch gleich mal an der
stelle auch weiter weil sie sind ja aus
einer partei die ja in den letzten
jahren auch verantwortung hatte für die
energiewende und deswegen ist natürlich
auch die klare frage warum kommt die das
sozusagen die erkenntnis dann erst jetzt
schön die forderung kann ich voll
unterstreichen aber die frage ob man
sich darauf hätte nicht vorbereiten
können den letzten jahren und sagen
können gerade auch die abhängigkeit vom
russischen gas und so weiter das hätte
man eigentlich sehen können deswegen
kann es unterstreichen aber kann nicht
ganz nachvollziehen warum man jetzt aus
allen wolken fällt mit ihnen da aber
auch ihr engagement nicht nehmen und
sagte das muss jetzt mal gemacht das
kommt vielleicht einpacken zu spät da
muss man eines sagen also in der tat mit
heutigen wissen hätte man sich nicht so
abhängig machen sollen vom russischen
gas aber hätte man vor noch zwei drei
oder vier jahren gesagt lasst uns doch
eine große infrastruktur für lng importe
aufbauen lasst uns doch auf anderes gas
setzen als das gas aus russland
da hätten die industrie da hätten
unternehmen gesagt auch viele bürger wir
wollen die bei das billige gas aus
russland das ist viel günstiger das
kriegen wir einfacher da gab es
überhaupt nicht die nachfrage daher ist
das jetzt natürlich mit heutigen blick
leicht zu sagen da sind viele fehler
passiert aber ich finde man muss jetzt
reagieren auf das was seit dem
angriffskrieg putins auch in deutschland
passiert und was das für folgen bedeutet
und was ich nicht verstehe und das habe
ich eben ja auch gesagt dass die
bundesregierung das gerade die grünen
sich jetzt dagegen sperren dass man die
laufzeiten der kernkraftwerke verlängert
weil wir brauchen strom aus anderen
quellen und das gestern in zukunft auch
immer noch für die
stromversorgung dienen soll und dafür
auch verbraucht wird obwohl es
eigentlich in anderen bereichen viel
dringender wäre das finde ich er geht
nicht zusammen und deswegen muss man
sagen ja mit heutigen wissen hätte man
vor einigen jahren einiges anders
entscheiden sollen aber wir müssen jetzt
reagieren und uns jetzt für die zukunft
gut kann er dass sie eine einzige frage
eine rückfrage was die atomkraft
betrifft machen wir uns mit der
atomkraft nicht auch abhängig also
atomkraft wirkt man ja damit sind wir
unabhängig aber uran produzieren wir
nicht mehr in europa das müssen wir auch
von anderen beziehen also ist die
atomkraft überhaupt diese unabhängige
schöne energielösungen jetzt gibt ja
viele länder aus denen man das beziehen
kann und wann genau und natürlich
russland ist ein lieferant aber es gibt
auch viele andere länder und ich würde
einfach mal unsere hatten dass wir uns
in europa umschauen gmbh man kann auch
die von anderen ländern nicht nur von
russland beziehen ja aber wir haben ja
das problem ist wir haben ja die
pipelines gebaut um das gas aus russland
zu beziehen und wir haben ja im
gegensatz zu anderen europäischen
ländern noch keine energie infrastruktur
dass er unser problem was uns da
möglicherweise ab herbst winter in große
schwierig kiten bringt war dann einfach
nicht gas da ist und wir im übrigen auch
in einigen industriebereichen nicht
einfach das russische gas durch anderes
ersetzen können das kommt dann auch noch
hinzu aber ich würde uns mal raten wenn
wir über kernkraft reden dass wir mal
uns in europa ein bisschen umschauen die
belgier haben gerade die laufzeiten
verlängert nach dem angriffskrieg von
putin auf die ukraine die franzosen die
bau neuer kernkraftwerke die finnen die
sagen wir setzen auf erneuerbare und wir
setzen auf kernkraftwerke um die
klimaschutzziele zu erreichen und die
energieversorgung sicherzustellen und
damit die menschen in finnland auch
günstigen strom haben und ganz viele
länder um uns herum machen das und da
finde ich sollte man sich das mal
anschauen und auch nicht sagen wir gehen
jetzt einen deutschen sonderweg und
stein aus kernenergie aus waren
eigentlich auch als cholerisch sagen und
haben auch schon gegangen darunter
angela auch aber den kann müssen wir den
müssen wir beenden und wie gesagt da
sind einige fehler gemacht worden ich
war damals nicht in verantwortung ich
habe den ausstieg aus der kernenergie
immer für falsch gehalten aber es bringt
jetzt auch nichts zu sagen vor zehn elf
jahren hätte man das anders machen
sollen wir müssen jetzt gucken wie
reagieren wir auf diesen angriffskrieg
von putin und viele länder ändern ja
auch ihre politik und sorgen dafür dass
die laufzeiten verlängert werden und das
brauchen wir auch in deutschland marien
kennen sie denn auch befürworter
verstehen die sagen nein wir wollen
keine atomkraft mehr in deutschland auch
nicht die verlängerung klar kann ich
verstehen
tatsächlich so sie können ja auch die
frau merkel und es war ja eigentlich
auch die politik mit der energiewende
und ich habe er so das gefühl dass wir
ein paar schritte zurückgehen aber da
ist natürlich auch immer die frage
welche alternativen haben wir wir haben
auch bei kernenergie immer noch das
problem mit dem atommüll mit der
strahlenbelastung auch mit dem uran ist
immer einfach zusagen hinsichtlich der
aktuellen politischen lage als auch
putin zu schieben dann trotzdem zu sagen
ja wir brauchen
ich finde das noch nicht zu ende gedacht
ich finde es gut wenn wir jetzt
mittelfristig diese lösung nehmen aber
langfristig stelle ich mir etwas anderes
vor ich bin aber auch kein experte im
bereich muss man sagen dass gerade
einfach nur mein empfinden
aber es geht ja jetzt um folgende punkte
einmal dass die menschen in deutschland
auch in zukunft günstigen strom beziehen
können und dass die energieversorgung in
deutschland nicht immer teurer wird also
jetzt kriegen viele bürger viele
unternehmen rechnungen und die sehen das
geht teilweise um über 100% schon nach
oben und wieder ein paar monaten wird es
wahrscheinlich noch dicker kommen viele
haushalte für viele haushalte bedeutet
das einen vierstelligen betrag im jahr
mehr oder deutlich so mehr das ist für
viele die wirklich ganz genau rechnen
und salmrohr ich komme vielleicht gerade
so bis monatsende hin oder am ende des
geldes ist noch viel monat übrig die
wissen gar nicht wie sie mit dieser
situation umgehen die haben ängste und
deswegen müssen wir auf jeden fall eines
beschießen nämlich dass wir noch für
einige jahre die kernkraftwerke brauchen
damit wir jetzt diese notsituation die
wegen des angriffskriegs von putin auch
auf deutschland ab dem herbst zu kommen
droht dass wir die bewältigen können und
da kann ich nicht verstehen dass sich
die bundesregierung dagegen sperrt und
wirklich möglicherweise dafür sorgt dass
wir ab dem herbst in eine katastrophe zu
laufen freiburg an sie setzen sich auch
für nachhaltigkeit ein was sehr wichtig
ist ein tolles gesellschaftliche
engagement denn sie das jetzt über
atomkraft hören würden sie mitgehen bei
herpes argumentation naja also man muss
schon sagen dass es eine ganz schwierige
situation im moment es ist auch so wenn
es natürlich die preise aufschlagen
warum wird auch jeder ein bisschen
bewusster auch mit einem umgehen auch
mit der energie und mit klar dreht man
die heizung noch eher ab- und überlegt
auch noch mal ok hat sich alles nochmal
vorlauf oder nicht das ist ganz klar da
muss man auch so überlegen es ist auch
ein bisschen wohlstand problem ok hat
sich jetzt meine ganze wohnung auf oder
nicht das ist klar auch krasser
nebeneffekt dass man für die
nachwuchstalente 7 frieren wenn sie das
so sagen tatsächlich also ich habs jetzt
auch nicht volle kanne auf das einzige
was ich mache zum beispiel selbst im
auto mache ich okay ich habe zur
sitzheizung zum beispiel mal die
sitzheizung an die verbraucht aber nicht
so viel wenn ich voll einheit so zum
beispiel das ist jetzt sag ich jetzt mal
auf hohem niveau ärzten gesprochen aber
zum beispiel auch im bus oder so dann
friere ich halte es aber haltbar merke
oder so an ich finde auf sowas kann
schon verzichten und keinen großen
beitrag dazu tragen habe was bringt es
uns wenn wir in deutschland auch solche
kleinigkeiten achten wenn man auf der
welt
darüber lacht woanders also das ist ganz
klar auch jetzt zum beispiel hier im
osten da ist die klimaanlage dauerhaft
an die ganze zeit also ich meine da
braucht man jetzt nicht bei uns
überlegen ok klasse ich jetzt da die
heizung rissen an oder drehe ich jetzt
auch 3 oder 5 das ist ja ganz klar ist
bayern denn ein besonders nachhaltiges
land wenn wir aus ansprechen ja also ich
finde tatsächlich wir machen schon sehr
viel gefeiert aber job gemacht weil alle
ja da gibt es am besten auf jeden fall
und ich meine
es ist auch ein zentrales thema gerade
eben ich werde darüber auch mal
getroffen arbeit schreiben dass mir ganz
wichtig haben aber ich gehe eher auf das
greenwashing ein dass viele nicht über
bayern die doktorarbeit soll das kühle
wasser überhaupt dann eben diesen als ob
die green sind aber tatsächlich er
nichts zu tun und mit dem european green
day was die europäische kommission macht
wird zwar versucht dagegen vorzugehen
aber tatsächlich muss man schon sagen
ist es auch eher bisschen image thema
also nur so viel passieren